et hop un petit rappel sur les motifs de
la manifestation quasi toutes les
organisations syndicales sont présentes
top départ cette fois ci les
participants sont scindés en plusieurs
groupes
probablement pour que tous les secteurs
d'activité mobilisés soit visible cela
fait plusieurs semaines que la réforme
des retraites est contesté dans la rue
aujourd'hui
la grande nouveauté c'est la présence de
très jeunes manifestants qu'ils sont au
collège et au lycée
ça nous concerne et c'est pourquoi nous
70 ans pour avoir une retraite juste
maquereau en lui-même dans son discours
la semaine dernière a décidé de dinde
imposé de continuer à mettre en place
des formes
maintenant elle est passée un peu plus
rien faire en quelque sorte mais on veut
montrer notre mécontentement
même si chasse aux bonnes et que je suis
pas totalement en âge de pouvoir être
afp à la retraite quand je croyais plus
grande joie que j'ai travaillé et j'ai
pas envie de passer ma vie à travailler
et à la retraite ne touche pas à
l'argent qui qui m'est dû en fait les
syndicats d'éducation se félicite de la
participation de certains élèves se sont
selon les grandes victimes de la réforme
des retraites à points avec un hp
il est important que les consciences
s'éveillent très tôt précise-t-il
les jeunes gens ont compris louis
d'allemands qui seront les grands
perdants de ce système de retraite à
points
ils n'auront pas dedans finalement de
carrière complète puisque
la carrière la pension sera calculé sur
l'ensemble de la carrière donc il faut
avoir
ils seront finalement paupérisés et de
plus pour ceux qui font des études ou
les années d'études ne sont pas
comptabilisés près de 2000 personnes
étaient dans la rue ce matin
le préavis de grève de l'intersyndicale
est toujours en vigueur
les perturbations risquent de perdurer
dans certains secteurs d'activité et
notamment dans les établissements
scolaires un certain nombre d'écoles
sont restées fermées aujourd'hui